morning let's get to this Southwest
Airlines best to Harry Reid airport
thousands of people still stuck after
the Southwest meltdown they've now
canceled almost all of their flights
this week and that continues through the
end of the week so let's get to today
around 200 cancellations so far 30
delayed flights all but 10 of those are
you guessed it Southwest make sure you
check your flight status before heading
to the airport Southwest has put out an
apology video with one of the executives
Ryan green talking about their website
where you can go to rebook flights ask
for refunds put in your information
about missing luggage he says they're
doing all they can to repair
relationships with Travelers meanwhile
the president of the groundworkers Union
Randy Barnes put out a statement saying
quote when you're dealing with sub-zero
temperatures driving winds and Ice
storms you can't expect to schedule
planes as if every day is a sunny day he
says groundworkers need more help that
some have been working 16-hour days
getting sick even getting frostbite in
the cold now to help with all the travel
problems some of the other airlines
American Delta United say they are
capping fares in select cities to help
stranded Travelers get home but we've
seen evidence of what would sure appear
to be price gouging John and Heather so